Y
FROM THE POLITICAL BACK AND
FORTH AND JUST TALK TO THE
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES RIDING THESE
BUSES TO SEE WHAT THEY THINK.
HERE'S GARY.
>> Reporter: THESE MIGRANTS,
MOST FROM VENEZUELA, HAVE JUST
CROSSED THE RIO GRAND INTO
TEXAS, SURRENDERED TO THE BORDER
PATROL AND RECEIVED FUTURE COURT
DATES.
SOME ARE ABOUT TO BOARD THIS BUS
FOR A 1,700 MILE TRIP TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., A PLAN STARTED
BY THE TEXAS GOVERNOR IN APRIL.
SOME PEOPLE SAY IT'S CRUEL.
BUT THIS STORY MAY NOT BE WHAT
YOU EXPECT.
LISTEN TO THESE MIGRANTS LIKE
THIS 28-YEAR-OLD FROM VENEZUELA.
>> ARE YOU TAKING THE BUS?
>> TODAY, YES.
>> ARE YOU HAPPY?
>> CI, CI.
>> LISTEN TO THOSE WHO ADVOCATE
FOR THE MIGRANTS.
>> THEY WANT TO GO ON THE
BUSSES.
>> Reporter: MISSION HOPE IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
SHE SAID MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
WANT TO GO TO WASHINGTON OR NEW
YORK.
YOU'RE SAYING NO ONE IS BEING
FORCED TO GO ON THESE BUSSES?
>> NO ONE.
>> THEY WANT TO?
>> MM-HMM.
>> THEY FACE AN AVERAGE OF 500
DAILY.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE HAVE FAMILY
IN THE UNITED STATES, FAMILY
WITH MONEY AND THEY'LL BE WITH
THEM IN NO TIME IN THEIR
HOMETOWNS.
BUT MANY OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO
FAMILY AND HAVE NO IDEA WHERE
THEY'LL GO NEXT.
>> THIS WOMAN TRAVELED A MONTH
AND A HALF BY FOOT, BUS AND BOAT
TO GET HERE.
SHE SAID WAS VERY TIRED, I GOT
SICK, CAME DOWN WITH PNEUMONIA
AND WAS HOSPITALIZED.
SHE SAID SHE AND HER HUSBAND ARE
HAPPY TO TAKE THE WASHINGTON
BUS.
THEY HAVE FRIENDS IN WASHINGTON.
SHE SAYS WE'VE BEEN ON THE ROAD
FOR SO LONG, WE DON'T MIND TWO
OR THREE MORE DAYS.
>> LUIS SAYS WE LEFT IN SEARCH
OF A DREAM BECAUSE NOW IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT, HARD SITUATION
BECAUSE THIS TRIP TOOK MY LIFE.
HIS BROTHER, JUAN, DISAPPEARED
WHEN THEY WERE SWIMMING ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE.
OFFICIALS INFORMED HIM HIS BODY
WAS FOUND.
HE DROWN.
THEY WILL GO AHEAD WITH THEIR
PLANS AND TAKE THE WASHINGTON
BUS.
HE SAYS OUR DESTINATION WAS
CHICAGO BUT ADDS THEY WILL GET
OFF THE BUS ALONG THE ROUTE IN
KENTUCKY AND A RELATIVE WILL
PICK THEM UP THERE.
THE BUSSES HAVE INDEED LETTING
PASSENGERS OFF ALONG THE WAY
ONCE THEY GET OUT OF TEXAS.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR THE BUS TO
LEAD.
THEN 41 MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN
COME OUT OF THE BLAZING SUN TO
BOARD THE BUS FOR THE 40-HOUR
RIDE.
GENESIS SAYS SHE'S READY.
SHE HOPES TO SUPPORT HER FAMILY
IN VENEZUELA BY CLEANING,
COOKING OR DOING RESTAURANT
WORK.
THE BUS PULLS AWAY.
EACH P